check it out
literally
that was the first shower
I'm definitely a week or so
gross Jeremy Renner has a sweet Spa
moment in the hospital courtesy of his
mom and sister following a snowplow
accident that left him in critical but
stable condition
he's so sexy
on Thursday the Hawkeye star shared that
clip to Twitter his family comforting
him from his hospital bed after he
suffered some serious injuries yeah
Jeremy wrote alongside the clip where
his sister massages his head and makes
him laugh quote a not no great ICU day
turned to amazing spa day with my sis
and Mama thank you so much I really
couldn't be more fortunate and yeah
Jeremy says that Spa moment was the
first time he's bathed since he was
injured clearing snow from his property
in Reno on New Year's Day that was the
first shower
oh definitely a week or so gross
a rep for the actor confirmed to E.T
that Jeremy was in an accident on Sunday
and underwent chest surgery to address
his injuries the rep also added that
he's with his family and receiving
excellent care Jeremy's latest post
comes just two days after he shared his
first update from the hospital a selfie
from bed thanking fans for their support
in the caption quote I'm too messed up
now to type but I send love to you all
just ready that's why am I was always
ready and when it was thrown at me some
of Jeremy's close friends and MCU you
co-stars swooped into the comments to
offer their love and support Chris Pratt
wrote continued prayers your way brother
Chris Hemsworth wished Jeremy a speedy
recovery while Chris Evans gave props to
his pal saying he's tough as Nails I was
saying like wow this is cool and Haley
Steinfeld who starred alongside Jeremy
and Hawkeye shared Jeremy's post to her
Instagram story and wrote quote come on
Partner thank God you're healing we are
sending you love and prayers for a
speedy recovery
he's so sexy
[Music]